personal question uh you're married yes
you've got kids yes how old are your
kids
uh ranging from 11 to 20. okay so you
got kids and they're in that gen z range
of gen z's been indoctrinated that the
world is falling apart on a personal
level i mean even even having
conversations through their kids or your
kids friends
on a personal level how does it feel to
you to know that you're the guy that is
that's rooting for earth to
not win right like this is this is the
argument
whether you call it the left that you're
the bad guy what did pat put it you're
one of the top five people who are
criminals against humanity yes so from a
personal level if i was branded a
criminal against humanity i'd have a
very strong like
feedback or pushback on that but
explaining to your kids like you don't
want the earth to fail you want us to
live right yes
i'm for human flourishing and earth
prosperity and that's why i argue it's
about technology it's about wealth the
wealthier a country the cleaner the
environment it's that simple it
literally
you know there was a young south african
activist i interviewed at the earth
summit who sees like the rest of the
world is bs we need to be doing
everything the africa africa has it
right they're living in harmony with the
earth well are they really if you go if
one billion people don't have running
water and electricity asia south america
africa
they have
uh their use the rivers are sewage yeah
there's filth animal dung being burned
horrible air quality low life expectancy
slash and burn agriculture nothing about
it makes sense so i consider myself a
champion of the earth because we want to
use
everything from high-yield agriculture
to sustainable forestry to use that word
where you you know instead of doing
swash you cut areas you make it so it's
regenerative and as quickly as possible
we've done this incredible success story
on endangered species rapid drop in
species extinction since 1870
on every metric and there's you know
there's a there's there's a
multiple reports one of the greatest
person on this is uh beyond lombard who
runs the copenhagen consensus who goes
through all the ways in which planet
earth
is bet is improving and how we can
improve it further and the way to do it
is technology wealth not a top-down
destruction of economic economic growth
so
i'm not against
solar wind and renewable energy per se
but i'm against mandating that energy
and banning energy that's proven itself
so because one of the greatest
liberators of mankind has been fossil
fuels but beyond that it's been also a
liberator of the earth because we have
when you have people on earth and you
have
economic progress
you're gonna you're gonna if you're
using the old methods what saved the
whale probably whale yeah oil
oil from to use then in in lamps instead
of whale oil i mean that was one of the
biggest things in coal
what saved uh you know what made our
cities radically cleaned up internal
combustion engine there were projections
in 1890 of every major city that horse
manure could be two two stories high in
new york city and other cities then what
happened the internal combustion engine
came along and basically had a massive
cleanup of all these cities in that
regard i mean there's always other
issues with but so i don't look at in
terms of my kids you know it's funny
because it people think like oh the
whole world thinks this way i live in
suburban virginia and
you know my kids have really
i'm all their friends think they have
the same view there's very few that are
all worried i've very few kids are all
worried in my lifetime experience i've
even spoken at high schools and spoken
at their schools
um i want to stay on this topic with
china i want to say i appreciate that i
appreciate the question but i want to
stay on this topic can you refresh this
i want you to see this from 1960 where
china ranked on carbon emissions and how
it's grown
refresh again so people can't see it
eric i don't know if you guys put it
live or not so the audience can see it
i'll wait for you okay go for it so do
one more time do it one more time this
is where china
starts off yeah the u.s is still the
world's largest historic contributor of
co2 but china is now the biggest by far
and you'll see and john kerry's
referenced this he said even if the
united states and all the industrialized
world zero go down to zero it basically
won't make a difference in global
emissions because of china india these
other countries look how much russia
dropped off by the way and then boom
that that acceleration in the 2000s with
china
and how it went up and russia kept going
lower and lower and lower and staying at
400 so refresh one more time to see what
happens from 1980 on
okay to see what happens from 1980 on so
look at russia's climbing
and then u.s has got a big lead and this
is not something you want to be leading
in this is co2 yeah this is co2 look at
russia's going up to five five seventy
five eighty five nine six hundred six
forty six forty five six sixteen and six
eighty and then look at russia drops so
what did russia do to drop and what did
china do
to increase from 2000 1995
till today okay great question
what did russia do russia collapsed what
a great way you you collapsed your
entire economy in all the eastern
satellites same thing happened in
eastern europe you're going to lower
your emissions but you're also going to
have misery but you just said the more
wealth there is the better it is right
you
you you just well that's
under a communist system they didn't
have
russia had
a huge increase until what because 1989
where berlin approached again 91
and then it collapses but then all
industrial activity stops so i don't
i'm not talking about co2 i'm talking
about an environment when i say huge
engines okay yeah yeah but even
environment i mean the u.s because we
did we switched from coal to fracking
natural gas fracking and that's why ours
chiefly dropped dramatically
defied every energy prediction in 2010.
but i'm talking when i specifically said
wealth it's greener environment overall
but also co2 but but russia has nothing
going for it they had a centralized
communist system then they collapsed and
then now they're under an autocratic
dictatorship i mean they're just have
it's not even a country that would apply
to the same standards anyway in terms of
that well china you asked what happened
i can talk about china in a second but
go for it i want to hear about china
that's how i was going to ask about
china well china as i mentioned earlier
ross perot was right in the late night
all these free trade agreements
and all of the uh
from from nafta the world trade
organization literally allowed and i i
blame a lot of the doctrinaire
free market
conservatives as well libertarians who
always said it's
if you can get your product cheap you
buy your product from the cheapest place
doesn't matter where those people who
buy american is nonsense
that would work in a world where the
people you're buying it from
aren't don't have an agenda to basically
crush you and use it again fully agree
and i'm a student of walter williams and
i was always saying wish he was still
alive he died about a year or two ago
economist walter williams and george
mason i um
and i knew him i interviewed him and uh
but i wish i could have you know in
later years asked him about that because
to me
that's what happened as we
gave away our industrial base through
these agreements to not just china but
also india we transferred not just
remember i said outsourcing pollution
outsourcing co2 we outsourced our wealth
our job creation and our industries to
these countries under the guise of free
trade because they were always going to
beat us under cheaper and now what we're
facing is china is essentially can can
rule the world in fact they when they do
stuff like lockdowns and we all follow
when they control the world health
organization along with bill gates it's
incredible how powerful they are but
economically unbelievably powerful all
the supply chain issues we are so
reliant on them now and i think we're
just waking up to what we've done under
republican presidents
uh chiefly i would say and some
democrats as well uh with all these free
trade and i call it free trade in quotes
but that was the huge economic transfer
when you go a little bit china's booming
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]
you